The cognotic desktop application is extensible. You can install a
plug-in by clicking Plugins from the main page, clicking
Upload Plugin, Choose File. Selecting the plug-in jar
You may want to check auto load and then upload
plugin. Upon starting this plugin
asks you to accept the license agreement, which is OK
and this plugin also requires you to be
on Patreon and verify your subscription status
This plug-in is for supporters of my
Patreon. Once you click allow
on that, you can close that and then refresh
the home page and you see some extra options that
we can go over in other demo videos. As
you can see, plug-in installation is simple, and adds working
applications.